I think people are afraid of what they
don't know I think that the German
movement means a feminist movement has
been very successful and actually do the
problems but I think more and more
especially with the internet and blogs
and Tumblr in social media when people
are coming to feminism and becoming
feminists every day I think people just
say that they're Pro gender equality but
against feminism don't really understand
what feminism is about gender equality
is literally the dictionary anyone who
is against feminism for social political
economic equality between the sexes is
actually about estimative they maybe
just don't understand what the words
mean to the sort of necessary Apple
gentlemen it's not so much I mean I
think part of that darío type comes from
the idea of so furry or this idea like
feminists don't want men's open doors
for them I think men and women should
open doors for each other and negative
aspects of chivalry the feminist has
criticized in the past is that it's this
assumption that if men to a certain
number of setting look like open a door
okay for a meal you know bring flowers
that they are owed something in return
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook